un viernes normal en un centro comercial
de oakland se transforma en la escena de
un ataque terrorista
en horas de la tarde un hombre hirió a
seis personas en un supermercado con un
cuchillo que había tomado en la tienda
el atacante murió tras recibir disparos
de oficiales encubiertos que lo estaban
siguiendo e intervinieron en 60 segundos
una rápida secuencia de miedo y
desesperación
este tipo cualquiera simplemente gritó
alláhu akhbar y empezó a apuñalar
primero a dos mujeres blancas que
estaban en frente de mí clijsters
volumen el apuñaló a esta mujer cuando
salía yo estaba entrando me arrojé al
suelo y había un hombre mayor europeo
tirado en el piso lo había apuñalado y
gasset a las autoridades identificaron
el agresor como un hombre de 32 años
oriundo de sri lanka quien fue
influenciado por una ideología violenta
y se inspiró en el estado islámico la
policía lo tenía en su lista de
seguimiento desde hace 5 años la primera
ministra hasina are there condenó el
hecho pero llamó a evitar mensajes de
odio
lo que ocurrió fue despreciable fue
detestable estuvo mal fue llevado a cabo
por un individuo no una fe no una
cultura no una etnia sino una sola
persona por una ideología que no es
apoyada aquí por nadie ni por ninguna
comunidad by any one week in exile nueva
zelanda un país con una tasa de
criminalidad relativamente baja se
encuentra en alerta por posibles
atentados desde que un ataque
supremacista en dos mezquitas de la
ciudad de christchurch dejar a 51
muertos un informe de la inteligencia
neozelandesa de 2020 señaló que ese año
fueron investigadas entre 30 y 50
personas por posible violencia
extremista y alertó por potenciales
ataques de lobos solitarios en el país